[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Workload
Identity allows
workloads in your Google
Kubernetes Engine,
or GKE, clusters to impersonate
Identity and Access Management,
or IAM, service accounts so that
they can access Google Cloud
Services.
Without Workload
Identity enabled,
your workloads will use your GKE
nodes default service account.
In this video, we
will show you how
to enable Workload Identity
on your GKE cluster
and configure your
apps to use it.
You can enable
Workload Identity using
the Cloud Console, the Google
Cloud CLI, or the REST API.
We'll first use
the Cloud Console
to enable Workload Identity
on an existing cluster,
and then we'll use the
CLI to configure an app
to use Workload Identity.
Let's get started.
Go to the Kubernetes
Engine page.
Select your cluster.
Scroll down to the
Security section.
And under this section,
click the Edit icon
next to Workload Identity.
Click the box to enable
Workload Identity,
then save your changes.
After a few minutes,
your cluster
is enabled with
Workload Identity.
Congratulations.
You now have a Workload
Identity-enabled cluster.
The node pool that we used
already had a test pod running.
Let's see what service
account it uses.
First, we'll connect
to the cluster.
Great.
We're in.
Let's exec into the test pod.
Then, run the following
command, gcloud auth list,
to find out which Google
service account is used.
It shows our nodes
default service account.
Let's configure our pod to
use Workload Identity instead.
Now, we'll use the Google Cloud
CLI to tell an existing node
pool to use Workload Identity.
We'll exit our test pod,
then update the node pool
to use the GKE metadata server.
This will take a few minutes.
You can also create
a new node pool.
When your cluster has
Workload Identity enabled,
any new node pools will, too.
Next, create an
IAM service account
for our pod to impersonate.
Now, we need to bind the
Kubernetes service account
that our pod uses to
the IAM service account
that we created.
Allow the Kubernetes
service account
to impersonate the
Google service account
by adding an IAM policy
binding between the two service
accounts.
In our case, we're using the
default Kubernetes service
account in the
default namespace.
Next, annotate the
Kubernetes service account
so that Workload
Identity knows which
Google service account to use.
Workload Identity
is now configured
with the specified
Google service account.
Great.
We have successfully
enabled and configured
Workload Identity
on our GKE cluster.
Time to test it out.
Remember, the test pod was
using the default node service
account earlier.
Let's see which service
account is being used now.
Let's exec back into the test
pod and run gcloud auth list.
It now shows the
Google service account
we just created and configured.
That's because we bound our
default Kubernetes service
account to the IAM
service account,
so the pod was able to
impersonate the IAM service
account.
Congratulations.
You now have a Workload
Identity-enabled GKE cluster
configured to use an IAM service
account with your workload.
Read more about Workload
Identity in the documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]